Just think for a minute,
whoever you are,
wherever you live,
whatever you do,
just think for a minute of your house being rubble.
Your home being rubble.
That's all. It's rubble.
And you have to
not just work out where you're gonna sleep tonight,
but you have to work out where you're gonna sleep
until somehow,
miraculously,
you manage to own a house again.
If you stay alive,
of course, which is increasingly unlikely
given the hundreds that have died
in the last two or three days alone.
And you know your house is rubble,
but at least you know you'll be safe
if you move from the north,
where your house has been rendered rubble,
to the south,
which you have, of course,
been told to do,
and you did,
and now they're bombing you there.
Um, the. The. The.
The displacement numbers are absolutely stunning
in all the. All the worst ways. So it. It.
It, as I say,
those moments where you stumble into the questions.
We did it. We did it on Friday, on the, uh.
What does he mean?
I mean, if you can't answer that question honestly,
what does he mean when he says,
nothing will stop us?
If you can't answer that question honestly,
then you've moved into the realms of lying to yourself,
because the answer to that question is obvious. It means
that there is no upper limit on civilian death.
In the frankly
spurious claim that this is going To somehow
either eradicate Hamas
or secure the release of the remaining hostages.
So that's all that's left.
They're bombing
the bit they told people to go to to be safe.
If that had happened on day one,
if they said,
right, go south,
and then the next day they bombed it,
what would the world have done?
You see how it works?
But we couldn't do that on Day 1.
So we've waited.
We've waited a few weeks.
We told them to go south,
and now we're bombing
the bit that we told them to go to to be safe.
Because the absurdity of claiming that this is how you
secure the release of hostages
held in the territories that are now being bombed
is so clear.
We have to play a longer game.
We have to be incremental.
We have to turn the heat up on the pot
with the frog in very gently.
We can't turn it from north to 10 overnight,
because then I support
in the English speaking world,
because I can tell you for sure
that it is largely confined now to America
and the United Kingdom
for reasons I don't fully understand.
Um, would begin to wobble,
as indeed it is the.
The vice president,
Kamala Harris,
responding overnight
in a way that speaks of some dilution of.
Of unquestioning support
for the continuing massacre of Palestinians.
But imagine if they'd started bombing the south
the day after they told everyone to move from The north.
What would she have said then?
As it is, she says this now.
International humanitarian law must be respected.
Too many innocent Palestinians have been killed.
I believe very passionately and very deeply in the
existence of the modern state of Israel.
I, I, I find it an almost unbearably emotive issue.
But I can't allow that
to justify what I see happening in Gaza.
So you can't pick a side to coin that horrible,
meaningless,
reductivist phrase.
Sadly, we live in a world where you're told to your,
your pro Israel,
are you? Then you must be anti BBC.
It's so pathetic
to see how our population has been broken down
into these sort of binary tub thumpers. But,
but you can't,
you can't call this anything other than a massacre now.
And you can't justify it,
frankly, on any level,
unless you are prepared to accept the
untold killing of completely innocent people
in the spurious pursuit of the guilty.
And that's the bit I don't quite get.
Why do you think so few people in the west
currently expressing support for the, um,
tactics, the current tactics of Israel?
Because this is what they do to supporters.
Anybody, not,
not just Israel,
but anybody who moves incrementally. You know,
you could draw parallels with all manner of movements
or manner of political movements,
but you do it,
you don't go from A to Z,
you go from A to B
and B to C and C, To D.
But then you make a mockery of your own supporters
because people were insisting
that there was no earthly way that any hostages
would ever be released voluntarily by hammers.
Therefore, we can justify the current tactics
and then they release some hostages.
People were insisting and.
And sincerely,
I think people were insisting that because of the,
um, instruction to move
from the bit that was gonna be bombed
to the bit what wouldn't,
you could make a humanitarian case.
You could claim
with a conscience clear
that the Israel was not embarking upon anything like
as barbaric a program as some of his critics claimed,
because they had offered.
They had offered safe.
Safe passage.
They'd offered safe passage to the north.
But now they're.
Now they're bombing.
So you see what I mean?
You can't defend it anymore,
because they've done
all of the things that you said them not doing
proved that they were behaving in an acceptable fashion.
How can. How do you. Can.
Can you prove that they're behaving in an acceptable
as well? They've
instructed people to move from the bombed areas. Um,
there's no way that the hostages would ever be released.
And all of these things
Israel takes away from its own supporters.
Taken away from me,
actually. On.
On October the 8th, I was.
I was fairly clear that Israel had the right to respond
in a. In a. In a.
In an incredibly robust and defective fashion.
Of course it did.
I struggle also,
while we're dancing around this subject,
I struggle also to accept that the country
with the intelligence
and military capabilities of Israel
has no choice but to bomb everywhere into oblivion. To.
To bomb the Gaza Strip back to the Stone Age.
It just doesn't work anymore.
So have we reached the endgame?
And for the millionth time in the last few years,
I derive no pleasure whatsoever
from the suspicion that we're about to be proved right,
if we haven't been already.
Because the endgame was always set to be
it doesn't matter how many civilians die.
Have we reached that now?
We reached the boat now
where everybody knows
that Israel
has little or no concern for the civilian death toll,
because if it did,
it could simply not be pursuing the policy.
But have we reached a bit now where everyone can agree
that the direction of traffic
proves an absence of concern for civilian death
and a level of comfort
which has been articulated by Israeli
politicians? Remember,
it hinges upon
a conviction that there are no innocent people in Gaza.
They are all complicit.
They haven't risen up,
they haven't overthrown Hamas,
they haven't
taken control of their own destiny, and therefore,
yeah, alright, I'll say it. They all deserve to die.
That seems to me to be where we are now.
And I think,
with respect,
you're gonna struggle to convince me
or persuade me that I'm Wrong,
cause I haven't offered an opinion yet.
I've only really offered descriptions.
And then attempts at explaining the observable reality
that all of us can see.